yeah same number and everything just go
right just a radiator left to dropped in
like Jabari Parker Peabody pianist who
did a [ __ ] go back on the floor Jennings
with a drive-in a finger roll over the
long arm of the Ave Davis ten point lead
is now a 17-2 to Milwaukee run Jennings
almost as much speed as Bledsoe maybe
more and a good three-point stroke as
well so the point guards have won three
for three from three by four
I did a combo for three was the
Milwaukee team now sauce and good job of
Jarell to get maximum or the basketball
with apologies to Tony Allen vote Jeff
Morris Zeller
well they feel very comfortable with
Brandon Jennings a Bremen as you point
out because he's familiar with the
franchise seller with a floater but
playing in the G League affiliate who
fell back in Jenny's guarded by jerel
step back Jennings of three it's through
his older cat so there's no problem
small turn in guns at the expiration of
the shot clock Jennings the rebound
Henson in front of the field and the saw
gets out of the way there's
for branding Jones but you have Marc
Gasol's playing well the Grizzlies doing
a good job of scoring in the paint but
this a smaller plate seven thanks to the
rounded end draws the foul
the game situations and Jennings you see
clearly understands that Ratan Mays
Jabari Parker five to shoot Jennings
pulls up and